i'm dustin ingram developer advocate for
Google cloud platform I'm really excited
to announce the general availability of
Python 3 runtime on the App Engine
standard environment Python is one of
the most popular programming languages
and growing it's well suited for a
number of use cases including web
applications machine learning and Big
Data App Engine has supported a Python
runtime from the very beginning more
than 10 years now you may have tried
Python on App Engine in the past and
notice that it was very opinionated
about what you could and couldn't do
this new Python runtime is very
different Python 37 on App Engine
is our second-generation runtime that
means it's based on open source Python
from the Python Software Foundation it
supports Google cloud client libraries
for services like cloud storage vision
translate etc you can install libraries
frameworks and other dependencies using
requirements techs and best of all
Python 3 I like to deploy web apps to
App Engine because my app scales
automatically up or down even down to
zero to meet incoming traffic spikes I
only need to think about my Python code
not the infrastructure or wiring that
runs my app and I only pay for what my
app uses and I can use App engines free
tier to easily try new things in this
video I'll show you how to use flask a
popular and versatile web framework to
quickly write deploy and test a Python 3
web app on App Engine once we've got the
app deployed we'll iterate on it a bit
to take advantage of some of those great
new features there are three files that
will make up our app app Gamal main Pi
and requirements text let's start with
app Gamal this file lets you configure
your app in a number of different ways
all we need to do in this file is tell
App Engine that we want to use the new
Python 37 runtime we do this by adding
these lines next moving down our list of
files let's define our apps behavior by
creating our main PI file this is where
we can define the core logic of our
application we'll call it main PI
because that's what App Engine uses by
default but you can call
whatever you want as long as you can
figure it appropriately we'll use flask
as our web framework but you can use any
framework you'd like as well by default
App Engine looks for a variable called
app inside your main dot PI file as you
might guess this should correspond to
your app we'll define an endpoint at the
root URL that just says hello world and
that's it finally the new Python runtime
understands the same requirements format
that is used by PIP and other package
installers and runtimes across the
entire Python ecosystem the requirements
text file because we've chosen flask as
our web framework will specify it as a
dependency in a file called requirements
text will add flask and pin it's version
to be exactly version 1.0 point to the
latest version that's currently
available pinning the version of a
dependency ensures that the next time
you deploy your app you won't install a
newer and possibly incompatible version
of your dependency which could lead to
breakage so now we've defined these
three files optimal main PI and
requirements dot text our app is
finished let's deploy it deploying is
easy with the g-cloud command line tool
once you've installed it and
authenticated yourself all you need to
do is type g-cloud app deploy to deploy
your app to App Engine
now that it's done we can type g-cloud
app browse to view the app looks great
now let's see what else we can do web
apps are usually most useful when they
can accept input as well as produce
output what if we just want to say hello
to a specific person let's see how we
can do this with flask by importing the
request object we can inspect the query
string parameters from the URL we'll
look for one called name let's deploy
that real quick with g-cloud app deploy
if we don't pass any parameters it stays
the same and says hi to the whole world
but if we add a name equals Python 3
parameter to the end of the URL we've
now passed that value into our app and
it's rendered as you would expect since
this is Python 3 we can make our code
even better by using f strings instead
of string concatenation or by sticking a
few emojis right in
our source code putting the emoji in
line like that is great but what if we
wanted the user to be able to include an
emoji of their own choice by specifying
it as text we could create a massive
mapping from emoji names to their actual
values and find and replace them in our
name parameter instead let's use this
third party emoji package which is open
source and available on the Python
package index this package provides an
emoji eyes function which will let us
turn text into emojis all we need to do
is add the dependency to our
requirements text file like so remember
always pin your dependencies now in main
PI we can import the emojis function
from the emoji library and then use it
to emoji eyes the entire greeting once
again we'll deploy it with g-cloud app
deploy now let's add the string : snake
: to our name parameter and see what it
looks like in our browser it looks great
so much more customizable so that's all
there is to making a Python 3 app that
handles user input and uses third-party
libraries from pi pi stay tuned for the
next episode where i'll show you how to
deploy a wagtail app to App Engine
feel free to ask questions in the
comments below and if you liked this
video please subscribe to the GCP
channel for more videos like this thanks
for watching
[Music]